hello everybody hope that you are good
impatient Traders that's what we talked
about in yesterday's video and that's
what we are in the other book straight
away because I want to show you those
levels of Interest where price could go
to really quickly to stop those stres
because yes we can see in the other book
52,500 and 53,000 what are those levels
why is there liquidity at those levels
are those stop losses are those limit
sell orders or are they liquidations
does it make any sense for the market
maker to go to those levels well
yesterday after uploading that video got
a Gua from the market make it and he
told me you got him again CP Mobile and
we're going to go through his plan again
um I think that at least what he's up to
so yeah we're going to try to make some
sense of their book
52,500 and 53,000 remember those levels
guys we're going to go through high
block Capital we're going to check a few
new things
that I haven't shown in YouTube yet like
for example open interest caps and then
we're going to go back into the chart so
I'll see you have look next okay when in
have Lo Capital liquidation levels first
that's the rule of the Channel first the
liquidation levels then the heat
map okay um let me change the setting oh
it's already changed perfect uh the
Delta is pretty much uh neutral only two
billion worth of short liquidations of
course again takech this amount with a
pinch of salt because it's not a
realistic number just use it as
reference okay but that is pretty much
telling me that you know the Delta
liquidations is is neutral is almost to
back to zero now there are a few spikes
here in the chart that I see that could
be interesting okay and they are mainly
to the upside you check that out okay
now the biggest spike is uh
52868 so pretty much
52.9k and the next one is a
53,1 okay those are short liquidations
that have already stepped into position
okay those Traders have already stepped
into a position with high leverage
trades and they are hoping that they're
right that that they are right um the
liquidations are at these levels okay so
between 53,1 100 and 52,800 uh that's
what is telling me okay there is a lot
of liquidity around 53k now if you go to
liquidation hit map we're going to see I
wonder something quite similar let's
check this out okay let me take this
like that okay we can see some
liquidations to the downside B uh well
around
$50,000 exactly but of course there are
not as many as to the upside you can see
how there are more yellow bars to the
upside right that means that there are
more short liquidations than long
liquidations currently okay and if you
notice here the the brightest yellow bar
appears as
53,1 15 that's also the level that we in
the liquidation level so what can we say
here we can say that a
53,000 area there are a lot of
liquidation so remember guys that red
bar that we see that we saw in the ear
book at
53,000 well those are going to be short
liquidations okay that's your
confirmation so 53,000 are Liquidations
in my opinion is the main level of
interest in the chart right now where
there is the most liquidity right now is
at
53,000 but I want to show you something
else this is a bit more for the high
time frame at least this is the way I
use it and is the open interest uh
profile okay I like to put in vertical
let's check for example the 90
days I like this bars to be thicker put
it to 100 and what do you see here guys
okay this is this is going to get quite
complex um I'm not going to give you a
full explanation because I could be
talking here for 5 10 minutes about this
it's explained in the course but what
you see here are a spikes of open
interest open interest refers to the
total long and short positions that are
already opened okay so limit orders buy
and sell limit orders don't count for
the open interest only count positions
that already opened all right so you can
see that for example at this level
42,700 00 there are a lot of of
positions already open all right many
positions open at that level same as a
51,800 and now my question is what is
going on are those 51,800 positions that
are likely short positions you can see
the spike there is is quite big spike
literally the second biggest Spike after
this one around 43k all
right so are those short positions
traders that have open shorts a bit too
premature because they're hoping for
lower prices and that what that's why he
explains that there are liquidations of
53k okay that's the logic that I'm that
I'm thinking of so once price goes below
51,800 these guys are going to be
possibly underwater okay if I'm correct
that those are short positions they're
going to be underwater and they're going
to start they're going to start to add
margin to their positions their
liquidations are going to increase and
it can get a bit nasty okay now I want
you another thing to notice that is this
Gap here in the chart that we can see
between
,200 and
50,7 okay that's an open interest
Gap that's a gap in the chart that's an
imbalance that is telling you that there
is a level in the chart where there are
not many positions already open so in
that area it's a good area for price to
go to consolidate and start triggering
those
orders uh that have been left in the
area Okay because that way you know the
market is going to gain some fees The
Exchange is going to make money if the
exchange makes money the market maker
makes money and the business goes on so
50,000 between 50,7 and
,200 that's a big imbalance in the chart
regarding open interest Gap that's in
fact the only inv I can in the open
interest all right so um you mean that's
this is why I'm trying to make sense of
this if there are so many already open
positions at
51,00 are those short positions if that
is the case then that explains why there
are so many liquidations of 53,000 so
perhaps we could go there first I mean
deviation above the range he do
liquidations stop hunt drop price back
below the range break it down from the
range and go for this open interest Gap
here around
50,500 okay does that make sense it can
maybe it doesn't okay but uh you have to
try to play with narratives of how you
interpret and visualize what is
currently going on in the chart because
that's the way to trade okay first you
have to make analysis A scenarios and
then you have to trade accordingly so
we're going to go back into the chat
we're going to try to make sense of this
and how we can trade this okay no no no
you are joking me look look at that look
at
that there you go
52,6 guys this is what we've been
talking about I can't believe it's
happened to me again that's a second
time already that I'm making the video
and this happens okay uh but well at
this you can see that ually that's an
educational video you can see it playing
out we're going to talk now about the
triggers but guys this is what we were
talking in yesterday's video what I was
talking now with the other book and h
capital um it takes quite a long time to
explain these Concepts because I want
you to to understand what it's in in my
in my mind process okay but yeah I think
we uh we're pretty much uh I think we
pretty much hit already
53,000 and I'm pretty happy with that to
be honest now what the triggers are for
this well the logic would tell me that
this move is a move to hit uh the
liquidations from those traders that
have already go short in this area here
in the range highs okay this what also
we're talking in yesterday's video
remember we were here saying okay we got
deviation from the chart that means that
price is going to go to the range highs
everybody knows that this is a range so
the retail Trad is going to play some
shorts here and they going to let them
run for ages what happens that those
liquidations from those short positions
get stacked up above these levels where
there are also going to be a stop losses
okay any Trader that has a small
Leverage uh position and it's playing
with a stop loss it's going to have the
stop loss Above This level okay which
has been hit right now so yep this could
have been a stop hunt let's see how this
evolves for this to be confirmed as a
stop hunt then we are going to need to
see this as a deviation similar to what
we saw here okay price if if this
happens then price will drop back below
the range highs that's when we can open
a short position okay the 50 in the 40
time frame is going to line together
with a range lows if we break below the
range lows and the 4H hour 50 ma that is
basically a new short Trigger or you can
even add to the position if you have en
Clos it from here from the range highs
if if we if this happens again and this
will go to 50,000 where they also have
this liquidity pull from this large
green candle okay does that make sense
to you because to me it does again for
that you have a clear trigger and is
that this has to to confirm as a
deviation and for that you need to see
price coming back below inside the range
below the range size that is basically
short
trigger you can take profits at the
range lows uh I wouldn't recommend to
take all the take profits at least uh
partially maybe at 30 50% of the
position if we drop below this level
then add again to the short okay and let
right until filling the uh open interest
Gap and this liquidity pull on there
right um that's basically my game plan
if we drop again below the range lows If
instead we start to see some
consolidation Above This level here that
that was basically the previous High let
me Mark it with orange if you start to
see some consolidation here then it's
very likely that this is not a deviation
okay and we could see some continuation
to the upsite and that would basically
be confirming the high time frame
scenario that we were talking about the
other day day let me remove all of
these sorry I want to be quickly because
I want to PL this video as soon as
possible for you to watch it but in here
you have a
resistance that resistance is there okay
so it's very important for price to
close Above This
level and if we confirm that this
resistance is the new support then we're
going to be a 60k very soon all right so
so that's where the continuation could
go up to 60k and then from that we'll
watch again but for now guys pay
attention because we are trading in in
low time frame uh my channel is mainly
dedicated to today Traders so pay
attention to this to this range over
here look I can mark it for you all
right that is the range that I'm paying
attention
to so that is basically how I want to
trade this okay drop back below the
range highs I'll open a short
position simple as that otherwise if we
consolidate Above This level then let's
see how the liquidation levels change
but there is probably going to be some
more liquidation to the upside and then
we can favor Longs again so that's
pretty much everything guys uh I'm glad
that at least the first part of of our
idea that it was that there was going to
be a lot of impatient Traders opening
shorts already here we going to get
going to be next that's basically even
yesterday's title for the video and yep
they've been next they've been stopped
they've been
liquidated um of course it's not a nice
thing I don't like when people get
liquidated I'm not the market maker I'm
not the evil guys but this is how the
market works okay and I'm proving to you
every day the market doesn't work by
conventional trading patterns the market
works by having many retail Traders
trading those conven trading patterns
and then another entity taking advantage
of that and making money from from them
okay that's how the market works and
that's how I try that's what I try to
explain in every video so thank you so
much guys for watching and I'll see you
soon